meat flavored water and Japanese robot
babies will someday rule the earth
Vsauce Kevin here
this is Milo hey it's Mario this is
actually a Nintendo parity found in
Sega's Alex Kidd but Nintendo paid the
favor back in Donkey Kong Country 2 by
sticking Sonic's shoes next to the
garbage can along with hey whose gun is
that bro V that guy isn't walking around
that cube for no reason this 3d
holographic cube is actually tracking
his movement and altering the image in
real time now if we could just add this
to omnidirectional treadmills we could
start building the holodeck now that is
truly exceptional some Hadouken x' are
controlled by hand and some hands are
hidden in Hadouken other hands though
after playing with your joystick these
risque sega ads were made for a British
comic magazine that clearly had a huge
pair oh no the Japanese robot babies
grew up and are ruling the earth
actually these girls are wearing LED
grills that are pretty weird but maybe
not as weird as the pain station this is
a pong cabinet that will burn shocked
and whip your hand if you mess up oh and
if you remove your hand you
automatically lose it's featured at the
computer game Museum in Berlin Germany
that's a pretty cheesy Charlie Chaplin
mask that whoa wait wait let's see that
again
[Music]
here's an iPhone gun attachment and
Lifehacker brings us some old-school
gaming wallpapers for your phone as well
as your desktop including my favorite
find the link below to grab one of these
it begs the question what wallpaper is
currently on your desktop and I'm going
to leave you guys with a riddle the
first person to get the real right and
explain how they got their answer will
be featured at the top of the sauces
channel page as our genius of the week
Michael the squirrel is very slow he's
trying to climb the tree and everyday
climbs three feet but at night he falls
two feet if the tree is 30 feet high and
how many days will it take him to reach
the top
also his squirrel father has four sons
their names are 1 Z 2 Z and 3 Z what's
the 4th son's name dick you know it
leave your answer in the comments below
and as always thanks for watching
you